I think it's a tough time for marriage I
you know I wasn't married 20 years ago
it's hard for me to say but I think some
of the things that make it a very tough
time for marriages are the divorce rate
obviously the expectations that marriage
is laden with and these X patient's
expectations include that you should be
best friends you should be business
partners you should be progenitor you
know breeders you should be you know
passionately madly in love and have a
sort of a romantic you know sunset
horizon and I think that some of these
and and and now especially with the
decline of the extended family which
used to provide more sort of social
support to couples I think there's even
more pressure on on parents you know
their varying their kids around to
soccer practice and to music lessons and
I I think there's just tremendous
pressure on marriage and then so when
you bring in the sexual question and you
have a marriage that's been going on for
20 years in an age that is highly erotic
eyes do you drive down the road and
there are these Calvin Klein ads with 16
year olds who are you know half naked
virtually and the stuff they show on TV
obviously is nothing like what it was
far more explicit than it was 20 years
ago pornography which I've always been
into at some level or another I mean
I've I know about it is a guy I mean
that's something I've always checked out
when I was a kid it was very hard to get
more explicit pornography and now it's
sort of hot and cold running pornography
into people's houses and I think that
spits are one of the things I look at
when I consider Spitzer's case I think
that and in a number of these cases
they've been a number of guys lately who
have you know been caught stepping out
and I wonder if he wasn't at some level
saying you know seeing stuff on the net
and saying this very explicit stuff on
the net and saying god I should be
getting this too I should get
this and actually giving himself
permission to do it because the culture
is so arata sized and the one other
factor i'd throw in is that I
anecdotally anyway there's just a ton of
sexless marriages out there so I think
that and I don't think it's bad to have
a sexless marriage I mean I don't have a
sexless marriage I have a sexual
marriage I'm really happy about that
it's not easy to attain and you know you
got to have the wife where the blonde
wig and you got to do I think you got a
trick yourself in one way or another to
keep the passion going but what I'm
getting at I suppose is that after what
I'm getting at what I'm getting at is
that it's okay to have a sexless
marriage and it should be okay other
forms of sexual activity maybe should be
okay too I think we should just get a
little more sophisticated about this and
if I look at one of the achievements of
my generation it was to take premarital
sex that portion of people's lives and
just sort of blow it up from no time
when it was illegal and moral or
whatever 27 years and 10 years of
premarital sex well that kind of fun was
delinked from marriage and was people
had it and now I think in a way when
when the baby boomers are creating this
sexless marriage thing maybe they should
also maybe d-link a little the sex from
marriage I don't know I don't think it's
that radical a proposal but I'm more
exploring these ideas than than taking
the stand on